[Musique]
on me présente souvent ce moment de
scène jim hostile je suis danseur
professionnel et j'ai le privilège de
voyager dans le monde pour partager et
vivre de ma passion la danse mais
aujourd'hui c'est jim que je voudrais
vous parler
je suis monté des centaines de fois sur
scène mais là c'est différent je vais
vous raconter une partie de mon histoire
qui n'a jamais été mis sous les feux des
projecteurs et généralement quand je
monte sur scène c'est pour m'exprimer
avec mon corps donc si je trouve pas les
mots peut-être que je trouverai les
moves qui fait
et je souhaiterais m'adresser via ce
talk à ceux qui ont des rêves d'enfants
enfouie en eux que l'on refoule dès la
puberté car on a peur de se sentir
différent
ces mêmes rêves que l'on tente d'oublier
quand on rentre dans la vie active parce
qu'on a plus de place ou de temps pour
rêver et je sais que parfois dans la vie
on sent seul
on a l'impression que le monde entier
nous envie
on n'arrive plus à avancer ni prendre
une décision on enchaîne les mauvaises
journées
en espérant que demain sera meilleur est
peut-être que parmi nous en train de
regarder il ya sept personnes bloquées
dans un moment de sa vie comme je
l'étais où l'on se sent seul avec ses
doutes
vous savez ce sentiment qu'on ans quand
on a le moral au plus bas
on ne sait plus quoi faire et quoi que
l'on fasse on se dit à quoi bon j'y
arriverai pas c'est pas pour moi si les
autres réussissent et moi non c'est
parce que je suis trop différents jamais
je n'aurais la chance qu'ils ont eue et
on se laisse vivre et en souffrent 6 en
silence pendant cette histoire commence
par je m'appelle gym et je suis un
enfant de la dass est ce que vous savez
ce que c'est qu'un enfant de la dass
ouais plus ou moins on en a entendu
parler souvent en mal stigmatisés comme
un cas soc pour moi un enfant de la dass
c'est un individu à l'enfance perturbé
qui a besoin d' aide avec différents
degrés d'urgence qui est déplacé de son
contexte familial puis placé dans une
famille d'accueil pour une durée
indéterminée
mais un enfant de la dass reste un
enfant avec des rêves et j'ai connu ce
faux départ dans la vie à deux ans
à deux ans j'étais en foyer puis j'étais
placé dans une famille d'accueil
je sais ce que vous vous dites à deux
ans souviens pas où on a des vagues
représentation ou des images des ce qui
nous entoure
mais moi je réalisais déjà que j'étais
différent
un de mes souvenirs par exemple je suis
arrivé dans cette famille le 24 décembre
au soir
le réveillon de noël ça vous paraît
peut-être évident pour vous de vous
imaginer cette fête mais moi j'avais
jamais connu cette ambiance conviviale
vu un sapin des guirlandes cette
ambiance familiale
et si je vous raconte cette histoire
c'est pour vous dire que ce soir là j'ai
reçu bien plus qu'un cadeau c'était une
main tendue un nouveau départ est-ce que
j'étais un cadeau en retour
ça je ne sais pas mais j'aimerais
profiter de cette occasion pour dire à
cette famille
à quel point ma vie serait aurait été
totalement différente sans eux et que je
serai éternellement reconnaissant de
m'avoir accueilli est considéré comme un
enfant normal comme un fils comme un
frère d'avoir appris à aimer apr a donné
et que je les aime tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
un autre souvenir septembre c'est la
rentrée scolaire pour des milliers
d'enfants et ce soir on est un peu comme
une famille donc je voulais vous faire
une petite confidence quand le
professeur demander quel métier on
voulait faire plus tard je répondais que
je voulais dresseurs pokémon
je suis pas le seul ça me rassure mais
j'ai très vite lâché la faire avec ce
projet parce que pour moi septembre
marqué la visite au tribunal pour
enfants où on devait dire ce que nous
apporte et psychologiquement cette
famille de motivation à rester même
parfois nos projets j'ai donc raté
plusieurs rentrées scolaires de mon plus
jeune âge à ma majorité
parce que je devais faire cette visite
dans le cadre de ma protection est
d'ailleurs le terme protection de
l'enfance pour moi il est inapproprié
parce qu'on ne protège pas les enfants
directement du monde ne trouve pas de
solution pour eux on est des dossiers
placés dans des mains de bureaucrates ou
autre éducateur spécialisé qui
s'enchaînent et connaissent parfois même
pas notre nom l'histoire vraie et ce qui
est dommage dans tout ça c'est que des
millions d'euros sont investis dans
l'aide sociale à l'enfance chaque année
pour au final aucune garantie de
réussite
ce que je veux dire c'est que l'argent
n'est pas une solution du moins ne
contribue pas à la construction d'un
enfant à votre avis
de quoi avons nous besoin quand on vient
de la tasse
deux choses d'une stabilité affective et
d'un cadre familial aimant vous êtes
d'accord avec ça pourtant ce qui m'avait
choqué c'était qu'on avait interdit à ma
famille de s'attacher aux enfants
confiés on lui a même reproché d'être
plus professionnel et de données -
d'amour dans ces cas là qu'on cherche
des changes le terme famille d'accueil
parce qu'on pourra trouver des centaines
de définition mais pour moi une famille
se résume à trois choses les liens
d'amour de confiance et de partage j'ai
grandi dans cette famille diversifiée où
je compte aujourd'hui quatre frères et
cinq soeurs âgées de 25 à 52 ans et j'ai
grandi avec une norme l'unité dans la
différence et grâce à cette famille j'ai
pu trouver cette stabilité et me tourner
vers un sport pour trouver ma voie la
danse hip hop très tôt le sport est
rentré dans ma vie et je pense que ça
dépasse l'apprentissage d'une activité
physique ça véhicule des valeurs
positives qui ont joué un rôle important
dans la construction
j'ai intégré le groupe neuf impacts on a
été champion de france deux fois en 2011
et 2014
la première fois c'était à orléans mais
l'aide publique
la première fois c'était à orléans je
venais d'avoir 18 ans imaginez un lycéen
qui parcourt le monde en show quasiment
tous les week-ends des répétitions
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin et à 8 heures
à l'école et ce rythme durant toutes mes
études supérieures
j'avais fait une promesse à ma mère
c'était d'aller au bout quoi qu'il
arrive aussi bien dans mes études que ma
vie personnelle
et s'il fallait sacrifier une chose ce
serait la nuit d'ailleurs j'ai très peu
dormi pour cette aide alors est ce qu'il
ya des parents qui ont des ados chez eux
encore à la maison lever la main ça va
ça se passe bien ouais comme ça comme ça
je vous la corde c'est une période un
peu difficile mais pour être honnête
avec vous moi si c'est plutôt bien passé
enfin je pense que j'étais pas trop
difficile à gérer
malheureusement j'ai pas de solution
miracle à vous apporter avec vos ados un
bon courage
mais j'aimerais vous dire comment ça
s'est passé pour moi à l'adolescence on
prend davantage conscience du regard des
autres sur soi on commence à se
renfermer sur soi même on perd confiance
on devient méfiant
aujourd'hui c'est devenu une force je
suis hostile c'est le nom de mon tout
premier groupe de danse au style crew
qui est devenu par la suite mon nom de
scène jim hostile pour faire un clin
d'oeil à mes années d'apprentissage de
mon formateur bac et le mot hostile je
trouve qu'il définit très bien mon
caractère dans la vraie vie au style
dans le sens où je suis obligé de faire
ma manière je vois tout le monde à la
gauche je vais à droite vous avez
compris l'enfant relou par excellence
l'esprit de contradiction pas pour se
faire remarquer mais j'avais besoin de
me rendre compte si j'étais capable de
sortir de ma zone de confort avancé ou
apprendre dans le cas où j'ai échoué
mais ça ne m'a pas toujours aidé et je
vais vous raconter pourquoi lors de mes
études supérieures en licence mozas
management des organisations du secteur
associatif
il fallait faire un stage dans une
structure existante or j'avais décidé de
créer une association pour faire des
passerelles entre milieux sportifs et
artistiques ce que j'ai fait mais lors
de ma présentation orale j'ai fait face
à mon procès d'étudiants tu as fait des
choix qui en assumera les conséquences
c'était cette phrase de mon jury qui me
restera en tête ou encore il ne faut pas
récompenser un étudiant qui va contre
les consignes données s'est montré le
mauvais exemple pour les futurs
licenciés
bien sûr mon stage n'a pas été validé ma
note fut ensuite réévaluée au final et
m'ont quand même attribué mon diplôme
mais si je vous ai raconté toutes ces
histoires c'était pour vous dire que
dans chacune des épreuves que j'ai
rencontré ma famille était mon moteur le
sport m'a permis de me forger un mental
et la danse une raison de vivre et je
pense que si j'avais pas eu ce trio
gagnant
j'aurais sûrement perdu pied
pied
il nous reste les mains pour trouver cet
équilibre est resté en mouvement quand
vous êtes déterminé personne ne peut
vous arrêter aussi bien dans votre vie
personnelle que dans votre passion la
vie est faite de rebondissements et de
challenge avec ses hauts et ses bas
comme un roller coaster
parfois on rate parfois on réussit l'un
d'eux va jamais sans l'autre être
passionné permet de s'imposer une
rigueur le respect de soi et des autres
appartenir à une communauté et évoluent
ensemble s'émanciper et relâcher la
pression
oublié les tracas de la vie cette vie
est un don parfois si courte donc
allez-y à fond sans rien regretter le
temps est ce que l'on a de plus précieux
à offrir
prenez du temps pour apprendre à vous
connaître vous re découvrir trouvez
votre direction en faisant vos propres
expériences
le sport m'a appris à être en constante
remise en question soyez ce sportif de
haut niveau qui veut toujours poussé ses
performances soyez à la recherche de vos
limites
étonnez vous développez vous
personnellement devenait autonome
investissez dans vos compétences pour
réaliser tous vos projets peu importe le
milieu dans lequel on évolue
il y un facteur de chance talent
relationnel mais surtout de travail le
travail amène la perfection comprenez le
process de réussite sauter dans la
spirale du travail soyez passionné par
ce que vous entreprenez vous n'aurez
plus jamais l'impression de travailler
est ce que chaque jeu
et vive et impassiblement à couper le
souffle
[Applaudissements]
être troisième au championnat du monde
représenter son pays finir dans le top 8
mondial reste pour moi un honneur et un
de mes plus beaux souvenirs
depuis 2015 je suis représentant france
de la marque
hip hop international je fais partie
d'un réseau de 50 licenciés qui organise
annuellement le championnat national et
les équipes qui remportent s'envolent
aux états unis pour représenter à leur
tour la france est cette année marquera
les 10 ans de la marque en france on les
fêtera au zénith d'orléans
[Applaudissements]
si je devais vous donner un conseil si
vous devriez retenir une seule chose de
ce message j'aimerais vous dire que
votre futur ne dépend pas de votre passé
vous pouvez devenir qui vous voulez être
ne vous laissez pas guidée par la
fatalité car tout peut arriver dans
votre vie ne dépend que de vos
perceptions vos choix et bien sûr votre
volonté j'ai voulu partager avec vous
mes expériences car je crois en la
rencontre déclic
ces rencontres inattendues qui m'ont
permis de m'orienter un peu plus vers la
personne que je suis aujourd'hui j'ai
décidé d'être humain à temps plein je
découvre le monde danse avec de
nouvelles personnes partagent des
moments avec elle et raconte les
histoires pour que l un jour puisse
raconter leur propre expérience
cette histoire finit par je m'appelle
gym 26 ans deux fois champion de france
de danse hip hop troisième mondial en
depuis 2015 organisateurs du plus grand
concours de danse hip hop récemment
nouveaux membres du soleil dans la tante
de mon contrat pour las vegas et je suis
un enfant de la dass
[Applaudissements]